this is a production of Cornell
University
my goal today is to share a few things
with you to get you
about your teaching and I know that some
of you are faculty and are currently in
teaching roles and some of you are
graduate students and probably will be
in teaching roles at some point so I
hope to to get you thinking about some
things I'm probably not going to go as
deep as some of you might like to think
but I can certainly recommend some
resources if you want to look at some of
these topics at a little bit deeper
level I do plan to have some
interactivity built in and so hopefully
you came prepared with the mindset of at
least being open to some discussion and
some questioning and so we'll see where
that leads so first I want to pose a
question to you and we're gonna do a
think-pair-share and I think that if I
understand from Travis that you guys
learned about some of these active
learning strategies if a little while
ago but it will pose the question to you
I'll let you think about it for a second
then you can pair up with someone around
you and then we'll have a few of you
share some of those so the question is
in your classes what does it look like
when students are getting you and so
think about that for a second
okay so let's go ahead and pair up and
share what you think with someone around
you okay let's let's rejoin let's come
back together and so what were what were
some of the things that you guys were
discussing what does it look like when
students are getting it if you can I
have a few volunteers to share okay so
the students are volunteering their
asking their own questions there you can
tell it because they're they're really
engaged okay what else okay I get it
yeah yes you kind of reading their their
body language and their the
psychological signs that they're they're
giving good and so I won't ask this
question but you can probably as you
were thinking about that we're also
thinking what's it looked like when
they're not getting it well hopefully
today I'm gonna give you some things to
think about so that we can really
generate this more in your classes as
opposed to the frustrating times when
students aren't getting it so I'm going
to frame my discussion this morning
around five principles and there are a
few handouts out and around and so you
can feel free to jot down a few extra
things if you want but five principles
that I think will help you create
meaningful learning experiences in your
classes so my objectives for today are
we're going to describe the principles
of experience you're learning and then
ultimately I'm going to encourage you
guys at the end to think about your own
teaching whether it's your teaching now
or whether you will have a teaching role
in the future about what are some things
that you can do in your own teaching to
make it more meaningful for your
students so principle one learning
begins with the existing knowledge and
experiences of the learn learning begins
with the existing knowledge --is and
experiences of the learner and so I'll
let you read this a little bit
so is this what we think about our
students they're just a brain on a stick
and nothing else matters no not really I
mean really it's it's this stuff this is
what makes us uniquely human are those
individual experiences and aspirations
and goals and and so I would contend
that one of the things we ought to be
doing as as instructors is getting to
know this student I mean we still want
to care about this one at least this
part of this one but getting to getting
to know this student so we know who are
our students where do they want to go
where what do they want to be what are
what do they already know what are the
experiences they have second thing I
want to bring up is there is no such
thing as a blank slate there's no such
thing as a blank slate so whether or no
matter what you're teaching your
students are coming to you with some
level of understanding or perhaps
misunderstanding of the concepts that
you're trying to teach there is no blank
slate and so if we go into the learning
environment thinking that there's a
blank slate we're starting in a
disadvantage it's really about trying to
figure out what is on their slate and
building off of that as opposed to
starting from scratch so principle
number one learning begins with the
existing knowledge and experiences of
the learner and so let me pose a
question to you so based on principle
number one what are some things you
might think about trying to do in your
classes to to capture principle number
one
do some kind of assessment at the
beginning of class the
okay excellent idea so do some sort of
an assessment whether it's formal or
informal to kind of gather what do
students know okay
one more idea that you might do in your
classes yeah so have them try to connect
with the new stuff you're giving had
them try to connect with what they
already know and that will help you do
that I do an activity with some of my
classes called a concept map and you
guys familiar with the concept map it's
kind of a way to organize thoughts and
so actually the graduate course I teach
on experienced relearning I do this very
activity at the very beginning of the
semester I had them create their concept
map about how people learn and then at
the end of the semester I have them
recreate that concept map and then I
give them back the first one that they
did so they can see the growth in their
own understanding of how people learn so
it's all all about what they know and
what they bring to the environment okay
so there are no blank slates that was
principle number one principle number
two learning is a cyclical process it's
a cyclical process and I'm going to walk
you through a series of little videos to
kind of help us think about maybe a
learning cycle that we might share in
common that we have been through and so
I'll pose this question to you how did
you learn to ride a bike and so I want
you to think about that for a sec and
kind of recreate some memories or pull
some memories out of the file storage to
think about what it was like when you
learned to ride a bike and then I got a
series of short video clips that I think
might demonstrate what some of us have
experienced
okay so I would propose that step one
for many of us well let me ask before I
give you what I think we asked you guys
what you think so what was weird is what
was step one for you guys and learning
how to ride a bike no recollection could
you could you read yeah well that way
that would be a precursor because the
wheel is a critical component of a
bicycle other thoughts yeah so getting
that first bike that you really wanted
to ride other memories so seeing other
people ride bikes okay any other ideas
yeah that yeah yep I think many of us
have similar memories that and so all
great and you're gonna see that most of
those things maybe with the exception of
creating the wheel in these video clips
I'm going to show you and so let me
start with this one and I think we've
got this where it's gonna work out right
okay and so I would propose that that
might have been step one and that might
have been when we got that first
tricycle okay and we probably did see
someone rides the bike before we got to
this stage so maybe this is step two
really other than step one but what are
some things that we probably had to
learn about riding a bike when we were
at this stage coordination okay Travis
yeah I mean the pedal it's it's a little
bit different motion it's not walking
it's a little bit different motion okay
what else might we have learned at this
stage yeah a little bit of balance I
mean the tricycle has a little bit more
balance in a two-wheel bike but still
you can't lean way over or way back cuz
you fall off okay
what about stopping on the tricycle how
do you stop on a tricycle either yeah
you peddle reverse or just stop pedaling
or you put your feet down okay so that I
would propose that might be step one and
so now I bring you to step two
okay
okay and so step two is when we got that
that new bike that there was a two-wheel
bike but had training wheels on it and
so what are some things that we probably
had to learn when we are at step two yes
steering's a little bit different on
that you know on the tricycle the pedals
are on the front wheel whereas the
pedals are back further on those bikes
what else we have to learn at step two
the brakes right and what kind of breaks
to those kind of bikes have yeah right
you push back on the pedal and when you
get good you can leave the skid marks on
the driveway okay what else we have to
learn at that stage yeah yeah it's
bigger it's up a little bit higher how
to get on okay what else maybe one more
thing the side of the room the side of
the room hasn't been as
yeah so you might get a little bit more
freedom particularly as you get a little
bit older mom or dad or whoever let you
be a little bit more freedom okay so our
our travel through the bicycle riding
Academy is continuing I'll restart okay
and so step three was the day that the
training wheels came off and of course
when I asked that question that's
usually where the people go is that you
know mom or dad holding on to the back
so what what what did we have to learn
the day that the training wheels came
off balance right Union balance is
really critical when you don't have the
training wheels okay what else we have
to learn at that stage you do you have
to maintain a certain speed because even
if you've got well there's a few people
that can balance standing still but I'm
not one of them but yeah you got it made
same some level of speed or you fall
over what else we have to learn that one
yeah yeah because most of us were there
right most of us tipped over a time or
two and of course we had some trust
issues with mom or dad hanging onto the
back because you know they and you know
those of you with children probably went
through this with your own children it's
you know they make you promise to not
let go of course what do we do we let go
every time and then I promise I won't
let go this time and we let go again and
so so it's kind of we're working through
that cycle we're getting better and
better so now I say we move on to step
four
so so step four step four we leave we
are a little bit braver and those
boundaries are a little bit further out
so what do you would we have to lose
lose what do we have to learn at Step
four safety at wear a helmet safety what
else we're probably getting faster
what's that yeah look out for our
surroundings we're probably getting
faster we're probably getting a little
bit older so mom or dad probably gave us
a little bit more room to stretch out
you let us take a few more wrists the
core sometimes would the wrist comes
those sorts of things and so you know we
after we run into our friend and we get
up and we get a band-aid on our elbow or
whatever else so then we get back on the
bike and when we learn to well next time
maybe we need to look at where we're
going okay so now let's see what's on
step five
OOP what happens at Step five now that
one that one was staged because I have
not found a great video for this yet but
Step five is when we got that first
bigger bike right and what did the what
do the bigger bikes have that the
smaller bikes don't have yeah everyone's
a handlebar brakes right and what do we
learn is a critical piece of information
related to handlebar brakes apply both
at the same time or if you're only gonna
apply one which one do you apply the
rear because what happens if you apply
only the front yeah and how did we learn
that either intentionally or
unintentionally we did something like
that right we flipped off and we said oh
okay I better not do that again let me
just work on the back brakes yeah yeah
yeah that one deck you could tell that
kid had practiced a little bit he is he
was he was there now I would contend
that our journey through bike riding is
still growing
okay a lot of wind noise on that one so
that was that was just a person riding a
bike on a leisurely thing now how many
of you would say that even if you
haven't been on a bike in a couple of
years you could probably handle that
today at least on level ground maybe not
on some of the hills you guys have
around here but on level ground so most
of us would say we can we can do that
with reasonable thing we've we've
reached that level although I don't know
about this campus our campus the
bicyclists are crazy about have to chase
him around too you know I had a
professor when I was an undergrad just
carry a golf club and he was infamous
for carrying this golf club around
campus and anytime somebody got close to
me start swinging this golf club he he
wanted the bikes to stay away from him
because they will zoom up right behind
him but so most of us most of us
probably have skill level similar to
that we could with a moderate amount of
success get on a bike and travel across
campus now would is that the pinnacle of
bike riding skill I see some head
shaking no so what might be a next level
of bike riding skill what are some
examples we're riding up the hill yeah
that's oh yea clip-in pedals i i'm too
scared to do that if you guys seen those
where you feed actually like attach to
the pedal and there's like a trick to
get your foot out that's not for me what
other kinds of bike riding might be the
next level yeah the jumps and the ramps
and and then you know the the guys that
do the racing and such anybody here do
like BMX racing or the mountain biking
or the like the Tour de France sorts of
stuff Racing's so but yeah so there is a
level and so this next one I found this
video by kid named Spencer and so I want
you to look at some of the stuff that
Spencer can do and think about how he
got to that point
and so any we have any Spencer's in here
now I you know I I think as a kid I
probably accidentally did some of those
moves you know flipping off or doing
some stuff I'm I always looked back at
my I've got two brothers and it it's
amazing that none of us have brain
damage considering the stuff that we did
as kids so what how do you think Spencer
got to the point where he's at do you
think it just happened overnight now he
had a lot of practice do you think every
one of his flips he worked perfect the
first time now he probably had a lot of
bumps a lot of bruises he you know he
he'd try to do a flip and he'd land on
his head or his butter his back or
whatever and he forgot okay what do I
need to do different he kept practicing
so he was working through and trying to
learn each time he tried something so
now I propose that one more step in our
bicycle Academy
so I would say that's where we started
so why are we back at that point now why
why are we back at that stage or we kind
of we're gonna be old and have to get
back on a tricycle one day yeah how to
teach someone so now when we're back at
that stage we're not the little guy with
the helmet on the on the tricycle we're
the parent behind the tricycle trying to
teach our child to do that and so what
I've tried to demonstrate with those
videos and getting you guys to think
back to your own experiences say I was
trying to connect to your experiences
with riding a bike to think about how
you went through that process and it was
you know if we went all the way to where
Spencer is I mean that might be at ten
or twelve year development cycle in
terms of bike riding and so learning is
a process that we go through that we
might call the learning cycle and I wish
I could have a good way to demonstrate
this three dimensionally the best way I
can describe it as a slinky you guys
know what a slinky looks like and so
think of this as as a slinky with with
multiple revolutions and so you know
somewhere in our being we've had a very
initial focus with the concept and we'll
stick with our bicycle example here so
then we have an experience with that
bicycle you know we got that that first
tricycle we had to learn about balance
and so you know we lean too far and we
fell off well down here in the
reflection phase we think about what can
I do differently what does that mean why
does this hurt and we think okay well
next time maybe I shouldn't lean quite
so far and we try it again and we keep
going through this cycle over and over
and over and we get that bike with
handlebar brakes and we hit the front
brake and we flip off and as we're
laying on the ground we reflect and say
dang that hurts
what don't want I want to do again okay
I won't hit the front brake and let me
try that again and so it's just a
constant ongoing process and so thinking
now to your own current and future
practices in your own teaching what can
you take away from about the learning
cycle relative to how you create
learning experiences for your students
what are some
you can take away to help you with that
okay so it's not always gonna go
successful and we can learn from the
unsuccessful attempts of things okay
good what else yeah break you down into
steps we can yeah that's an excellent
thing and sometimes we forget that we
all have advanced degrees in our
respective areas many times the students
that we're working with especially the
undergrads and even some of the grad
students they don't have near the the
frame of reference that we do okay what
else Travis that's a good point and I
would contend and this comes from my own
personal experiences and as well as in
the work that I do at the University of
Florida I get the opportunity to do a
lot of peer observation of other faculty
all over the college and so one of my
observations is that as faculty and as
instructors we can get to be pretty good
at providing a lot of creative
experiences for our students I mean we
can come up with lots of cool
experiences for them and we invest a lot
of effort up here but we probably don't
place near enough emphasis down here so
we might create a very cool experience
in the greenhouse where the students are
growing out a crop of whatever and we'll
talk to him about that but then we don't
help them reflect and generalize based
on that experience we just jump right to
the next experience and so some of your
students are probably fairly self
reflective and are themselves hitting
these steps but I would contend that
some of your students probably they're
just sticking up here they're not really
learning from it and they're jumping to
the next experience so you know I would
suggest that one thing you can do is is
intentionally design activities to help
your students reflect about what you're
doing
figure out what the next step is and
work through the learning cycle okay so
principle two learning is a cyclical
process
principle number three learning is about
transforming experiences so we talked a
minute about creating those experiences
learning actually happens about with the
transformation of those experiences and
so what I mean by this is as educators
one of our goals or our goal is to help
take things that exist out here in the
wide wide world and help put them here
in the brains of our students now my
campus tour today I got to go into the
cycle the psychology department actually
saw a bunch of human brains and jars
which was kind of interesting but it's
about it's about transforming those
experiences and it's not as simple as
checking into a hospital and having a
surgical procedure where they you know
stitch you open and dump it in and
stitch it closed if they could do that
we'd be out of a job because they
wouldn't need us to help our students
learn but it's about transforming those
experiences for our students now and
this might sound like a very simple
question but I think it's an important
one as we think about what we do as
educators and what we think about as far
as the types of experiences that we
create but what mechanisms does the
human brain use to get information
how does our brain get information our
senses right are our eyes and nose and
ears and and mouth and so so we our
brain receives information through
sensory inputs from our five senses and
so as we are thinking about creating
experiences for our students to
transform we're really thinking about
creating opportunities for our students
to use their senses to grasp the the
information the concepts that we want
them to do now I'm not gonna pass
judgment on Cornell but I'll point right
at the University of Florida I travel
around and look in many of our college
classrooms and which two senses do you
think that we probably over use in the
way that we teach them at least on our
campus eyes and ears eyes and ears and
sometimes that's not even the eye
sometimes it's a lecture with no
illustration but its eyes and ears and
so we really rely on the eyes and the
ears and you know that for some concepts
that's not a bad way to go about it but
I would contend that there are probably
plenty of opportunities where we might
think about taste and smell and touch
and what can we do to provide a more
sensory rich experience for our students
I mean some of the stuff that you guys
do with the fruits and the vegetables
and stuff I mean you let them taste it a
little touch it let them do whatever
they smell it whatever they need to do
to really get that and it's about as the
information is traveling into our brain
the more ways and the more modalities
that we can get it in there that deeper
it's going to be embedded and the
learning is going to be even stronger so
schematically what might that look like
this is a model of cognition called the
information processing model and this
was has some parallels to the way a
computer works is actually in
educational psychology during the time
when they were developing this model it
was in the early ages of the computer
age and so they drew some parallels from
it but it to me it makes pretty decent
sense about how that works and so we
have some sort of an input through our
senses through our senses transformed
into working memory or short-term memory
and then
stored into long-term memory and then
when we need to use it it's pulled back
into into working memory okay so that
into make sense probably said to most of
you but I want to put a couple other
layers on that relative to the things
we've been talking about so if we think
about this in terms of where these
things are happening I would contend
that these things are happening outside
of the person so we're providing these
experiences so I on a daily basis in
your classes when you create learning
activities for your students you're
you're creating these sensory input
opportunities for the students okay this
half is what's happening inside up here
this is the part we can see pretty
easily this is the part that we hope
that's happening and when students are
getting it we think we see evidence that
this is happening but but not always
then to put it one more layer on it if
we think about our learning cycle model
that we just saw
this is providing the experience this is
providing the reflection and
generalization and so I would contend
that if we only focus on this part this
part may or may not be happening as well
as we would like and so I think it's
important to to really complete that
cycle to where we're providing
opportunities for the students to to
really internalize that at a cognitive
level so our principle number three was
that learning is about transforming
experiences and so thinking about the
few things that we just talked about
what are some things that you might
think about well I can do this different
in my classes that might make a
difference few ideas
the question would the reflection of
generalization I mean I have a lot of
experiences but to get students to stop
and I'm selective generalize what have
you seen why yeah so what's worked
effectively for you I know you bet I
know you're well enough to know that it
might be journaling it might just be
some discussion it might just be some
thought-provoking questions
the short sound bite and
yeah good get a different have them
teach it yeah so in anything to really
just pause for a few minutes and have
the students do something that forces
them to think about it whether it's a
think-pair-share
there's a little activity called a
minute paper where they just exactly 30
60 seconds they write down what they
just learned or you know anything to get
them discuss with with a colleague
journaling anything just to pause and so
you know if you are accustomed to
lecturing for 50 minutes straight if you
want to make an immediate change one
thing might be lecture for 10 minutes
then do a quick little activity to get
them allow them to think lecture for
another 10 minutes then give them a
little activity to think about what
you've done just ever to break it up a
little bit and so one of the things that
we really want to do and suggest is that
implement variety in what you do and so
you know you might like think-pair-share
and it might make sense to you but that
doesn't mean it's gonna make sense to
all your students and so you want to
implement some variety in what you do so
that your students can you can reach a
greater number of students yeah
everything
yeah that's a good thing yep yep that's
that's the next 90 yeah so there's no
magic bullet just you know whatever
figure out what's gonna work for you and
your situation your students and and
occasionally pause and let your students
actually think about what it is that
you're doing okay so we'll move on
principle for learning is about building
connections learning is about building
connections and so I want to introduce a
term to you called brain plasticity and
it's the the cool thing about learning
is that learning actually causes a
physical change in the human brain and
so if we think about what we do as
educators we we think about imparting
knowledge to our students helping them
learn things we are actually hopefully
causing some physical changes in the
human brain and so that was a pretty pat
when I first learned that it was a
pretty powerful thing to me as an
educator to think about you know the
efforts that I'm making even though I
may not be able to see them is causing a
physical change in in the human brain
now if we were wanted to be at a
scientific level and you want to inject
a bunch of dye in somebody's brain and
put it under a very powerful microscope
you could see it it's about building and
breaking brain synapses and those are
the natural electrical connections in
the human brain and so if you're
interested in this sort of stuff you can
go google it and look it up in the in
the biomedical literature but it really
causes a physical change in the human
brain now some of you might be
comfortable at the microscopic level I'm
certainly not comfortable at the
microscopic level so I like to think it
more the theoretical and what can i what
can I see and what can I do and so
there's a concept called cognitive
schema that to me makes a lot of sense
in how to think about how people learn
if we think about cognitive schema it's
it's I visualize it as kind of a web of
knowledge with each one of these modules
being
discreet piece of information and so if
we go back to our bicycle riding example
this one might be pedaling and this one
might be balance and this one might be
turning and this one might be handlebar
brakes and so forth so we've got this
existing web of knowledge now let me
pose a question to you thinking about a
novice versus an expert how do you think
these schema might differ
yeah so the expert is going to have more
connections between here and the expert
we'll probably also have more nodules
and so it'll be much more connected and
so you all in your respective areas in
probably have a very well-developed
cognitive schema around whatever it is
that you do I would contend that your
students when they come to you probably
have a very skeletal one with either
some missing connections or maybe some
connections that are actually wrong and
need to be broken and so the challenge
is then so as an educator we present
that new piece of knowledge and we are
very good at this we can create a
lecture we can create an experiment we
can create a reading we can do this very
well we can give lots of new knowledge
but what's what's the problem with what
we see right here it's not connected
right it's not connected and so this is
where you guys get very frustrated and
I've been there myself where you say
dang and I taught them that how come
they can't figure this out well it's
because they have this piece of
knowledge they just never made the
connections that it fits out here and so
it's just laying out there by itself and
so if you ask them to give you back that
information in the exact same way that
you gave them that information they can
probably do that but if you ask them to
use that information in a different way
they're like it doesn't make sense it's
it's not connected and so it's all about
building these connections and that
comes back to the notion of building
those the opportunities for reflection
and generalization to help your students
figure out how does this new piece of
knowledge connect with with the existing
knowledge now the challenging thing is
you get that brand new class at the
beginning of the semester and you've got
30 students in it or whatever and so
they're in your class and each one of
your students has an existing cognitive
schema how many of those 30 students are
going to have the same cognitive schema
zero-zero now they might have some
shared experiences if you teach a senior
level course in the major and your
students have taken pretty similar
courses to get to that point there's
probably some similarities in their
schema but they're never going to be the
same that the challenging part and also
sometimes the exciting part is teaching
those introductory classes when you
don't have a clue what they know but
they bring in a lot of interesting
experiences in there so again it's all
about building connections and so that's
principle four and I'm getting close on
time on our nail am i okay okay I want
to save a little bit of time for
questions so as we help the students
process so we give them that new that
new piece of information and we
introduce that new concept there's
really two general ways that we can
think about that new piece of knowledge
either the they're going to assimilate
it so if that new concept that new
experience fits with their existing
schema they're gonna kind of say okay
that makes sense it fits or they might
have to accommodate that new experience
if it's different or if it's
inconsistent or contradicts what they
already know and so they can probably
process these sorts of things a little
bit quicker than they can these sorts of
things and so it's all about providing
opportunities to help your students
figure out how does this new piece of
information fit and that's where that
reflection of that generalization can
help kind of to tie that loop back
around so that's principle four it's all
about building connections and so in
your own teaching what are some things
that you might be able to do to help
your students build those connections
okay yeah so give them different
opportunities to kind of experience that
and help build those connections good
what else yeah he can and it's very nice
if you can organize your your course or
whatever around a broader conceptual
framework and keep tying back to that
framework to help the students see where
it fits because it might be crystal
clear to you that a plus B plus C equals
D to students it may not be and so
having that larger graphic organizer
will help do that good I want to take a
quick in mind when I teach my classes I
said we'll take a quick timeout earlier
that was demonstrating wait time so when
you ask a question and you just wait
until it's awkwardly silent and then
someone is willing to give you an answer
and so when you ask a question don't
feel afraid to have the awkward silence
because sooner or later someone why I
will give you a good answer so other
ideas about providing that helping
students make those connections
that's that's an excellent way so
connecting it with Clint connecting a
new concept to a different kind of
experience that has some similarities to
it good good
okay so principle five teaching is about
creating meaningful learning experiences
teaching is about creating meaningful
learning experience and we talked about
the learning cycle and we talked about
that we are are very good at creating
learning experiences and so I want to
throw a couple ideas out at you about
creating meaningful learning experiences
things that are really gonna engage your
students and drive things home the first
thing I want to do is talk to you about
just a couple of differences between
teaching and facilitation and sometimes
we like to throw those words around a
little bit but I would argue that most
of the time the meaningful learning
experiences are happening when we are
facilitating the learning process as
opposed to teaching and so in teaching
the teaching that the teacher delivers
the knowledge and facilitation the
learner constructs the knowledge okay so
a subtle difference teaching instruction
is rigidly planned facilitation it's
more flexible and spontaneous and we're
open to those anomalies that happen that
we weren't expecting and teaching the
teacher has very strict control over the
environment and facilitation the teacher
and the learner share the control of the
environment and teaching the learners
are passive and facilitation the
learners are active and so I would
encourage you to think about your own
teaching right now figure out okay where
do I where do I fit on this continuum
and are there some things that you can
change to maybe inch over this way now
it's a little bit intimidating sometimes
to to go into a class session and have a
rough idea about what you think is gonna
happen in that class session but based
on the interactions with the students it
might go a slightly different direction
than you were you were planning and so
it's you know it's it's tough sometimes
that's the instructor to give up a
little bit of that of control to say
okay we're gonna we're in this together
and I'm gonna help facilitate this
process but you're not getting off easy
you got to contribute as well so I'd
encourage you to think about that
the other idea I want to present to you
is called Dale's cone of experience how
many of you have heard of Dale's cone
okay so a couple and so Dale's cone and
this really it's actually pretty dated
but it's a pretty it's a seminal work
from from edgar deo and it comes out of
the educational media literature but
it's really about as we think about
creating those experiences for our
students we have choices to make and how
we choose to present that everything
from up here
which is all symbolized which is very
abstract to things that are down here
which are very concrete and very direct
and so an example might be if we were
gonna teach how many of you teach some
sort of plant identification okay so I
figured in this department or be a
handful you guys that teach those sort
of courses and so as we're teaching
those sorts of courses we can make some
choices about how do we have what how do
we want to teach that well we might be
up here and talk about what plants look
like we might be appearing to show
drawings about what plants look like we
might show pictures of plants we might
come down here but when possible and
practical let me see the real thing and
so I would encourage you to think about
as you are teaching concepts in your
classes when it's possible and when it's
practical to think about what can I do
to provide direct personal interaction
of with the students with the concepts
now logistically and sometimes it's just
impractical to do those sorts of things
but I would contend you know if if you
can let them see the real thing and do
the real thing and touch the real thing
then give them the real thing let's not
come up here so I would encourage you to
think down there where we are really in
the doing phase as opposed to the
observing or the symbolizing next thing
I want you to think about is what I call
let's add some real world experiences to
to what we do and so I would propose
that in a class you might add some
things like guest speakers I know you
guys have have world class faculty here
but let's pipe a pipe
hypothesized for a minute that maybe
there is an expert that knows something
better than someone here does why not
invite that person in or Skype that
person and that's a beautiful thing now
what technology is is you can bring
anybody you can bring anybody into into
the classroom pretty easy field trips
again it's about going to see the real
thing get your students involved in in
research do service-learning projects do
outdoor adventure learning sorts of
things where you're getting the students
some direct purposeful experience with
those things now activities outside of a
course that are more at the program
level might be things like internships
study abroad experiences or broader
research projects and I don't know about
on this campus but I suspect you guys
are similar to us that we've got a lot
of bright energetic students that are
begging for opportunities and on our
campus we probably don't make good
enough use of all these energetic bright
young people in the other work that we
do in the research and extension
activities that we do I would contend
that there are probably some great
opportunities to get those students
actively engaged in a variety of things
so principle 5 was creating those
meaningful learning experiences so now
we're going to talk about let's take
this home what can you do and so we're
gonna go back to another
think-pair-share and so I want to ask
you guys two very specific very concrete
things that you could take away from my
discussion today to immediately at least
in cases that the faculty immediately
for the grad students at some point in
the future two things that you can
immediately take away to make an impact
on your teaching so think about that for
a sec and then pair up with with someone
around you and share your ideas let's
reconvene we'll get a few ideas shared
and then we'll save a few minutes for
questions and so let's let's hear a few
examples and and Geneva I'll give you
guys a heads up I'm going to call on you
guys in just a minute so you guys can be
thinking too but whatever a few examples
of things that the you could immediately
implement in your teaching for the
faculty or for the grad students
something that you could
to do in the future so a few examples
okay not lecture as much
okay yeah help help your students draw
the connections out of a guest speaker
so it's not just this anomaly where this
strange person was here for a day now
they're gone to have to pull some
meaning out of that good
another example yeah yes yeah so after
we've had that experience to help the
students kind of draw some so wasn't
just a cool day outside the classroom it
was actually there was some meaning and
help the student pull that out so Geneva
what about you guys what's something
that some of you guys might choose to
implement
great idea how about one more example
from Geneva
yeah yeah that that's an exit you know
you you know you guys gonna have a lot
of kinesthetic learners and just having
you of course the danger is sometimes I
can be a distraction where they might be
playing with it and not listening to you
but at least they're getting some that
any other examples in here or maybe we
can shift over to questions yeah yeah I
mean that the world is our campus and
then particularly now with technologies
we can you know we can travel around the
world in a very easy way where in the
past it hasn't been quite so easy so I
think we've got a few minutes for
questions and so I'll take a few
questions
yeah
well it is assuming that the students
actually do it it is better than nothing
but there's a concept now and I'm
actually playing around with it in one
of my undergrad classes it's called the
flipped classroom have you guys heard of
that terminology before and it's the
whole notion of let's take the basic
knowledge level stuff and do that as
homework in the form of online lectures
and readings and let's use class time
then for the deeper discussions and the
reflections on that and so you might
think about you know are there some ways
that I can do some things are there some
things that I can take out of the
face-to-face time to provide more
opportunities for the face-to-face time
because I mean let's face it I mean how
many of you carry around something that
looks like this most of you probably do
and I hate to break it to you but
everything that every one of us knows is
available on this little device and so
the benefit our students get from us is
not the knowledge they can get the
knowledge anywhere they get the benefit
of interacting with us so that we can
think like a plant breeder or think like
a weed scientist or think like an
educator or think like a whatever you
are think like so the students can learn
and interact with us so that they can
learn to think like whatever it is we
want them to think yeah very good very
good very good and I think it's Carol
Dweck who had some groundbreaking
research that looked at the impact of
all of this positive judgment
essentially all of this praise you're so
smart you're so beautiful you're so
great is creating generation of
risk-averse learners who are really
afraid to make mistakes and I think you
know we're seeing an impact of that in
our classes what are some very concrete
ways in which you have fostered a
healthy risk-taking in your teaching
expertise but I can share some personal
examples and it's it's about creating an
environment where being unsuccessful is
okay and it's about learning from those
mistakes and I teach classes on teaching
methods and so I teach all day about how
to teach and then conversely at the end
of the semester I ask my students to
evaluate my teaching so it's a little
bit intimidating to talk about the
entire semester about this is how you
teach good oh by the way evaluate my
teaching but I will periodically throw
myself out there and say okay I just did
this activity let's critique it and so I
the behavior that I hope that they can
see yeah and I also in the way that I
evaluate student work I tend to be very
proactive in providing constructive
feedback and I try not to be penalizing
in the way that I provide that feedback
to you know did you think about this
what could you do to make it better and
to provide some constructive feedback
and and I also try to provide very quick
feedback to my students because if if
we're teaching a course where the
concepts build on each other and you
talk concept one and then tested it and
then you're on concept before before you
get feedback from concept one the
students might have some misconceptions
they don't even know that they have by
the time that they get there so that's
our students at that Florida are like
that I mean they've gotten straight A's
their entire life and so anything less
than a straight a is failure to them
even though they haven't earned a
straight a yeah
yeah when it's it's the the classroom
comes a very fun and dynamic place
although it can be a little bit
intimidating at times too because you
don't know what's coming next
information students in cases you can
say give a relationship between two two
factors in a table of numbers or in a
graph personally I gained so much more
and it sticks with me a lot better if
it's a graph form you can see the shape
I can see the defects or whatever and
for a lot of people that is the way that
they like to receive information I would
encourage you to think about in a given
class of any size you're gonna have
differing kinds of students in that
class and as instructors we tend to be
most comfortable teaching the way that
we like to have been taught when we were
students but to recognize that all your
students aren't exactly the same and so
it's about presenting things with some
variety in the way that you do that so
if you present those those graphs and
those charts and and that's gonna reach
those kinds of a student and then you're
gonna you know deliver that that
fabulous lecture that's very engaging
and you're gonna reach those kind of
students and then you're gonna do an
activity that involves the students out
in the greenhouse or whatever and you're
gonna engage those kind of students so
it's really about providing that variety
of different kinds of experiences for
the students but I would I would look
for opportunities and tying it back to
when we talked about the sensory inputs
look for opportunities to engage all
five senses when practical and when
appropriate as opposed to just the
visual and auditory that we often do
another question yeah so he introduced
to the moves where you have 10,000
students
you can see and from what I understand
in now and the reflection and
generalization part of the learning
process is really done by small groups
of students with each other so that's
about the end of my knowledge right
there but could you touch on how this
process that I've seen that Jane was
saying chipped in to the online
environment it does create some
different challenges and also creates
some opportunities and and reflection
does not have to be just in small groups
it can be but you've got you're gonna
have some learners that are very social
in the way that they learn and they're
gonna they're gonna want to share with
their peers but you're also going to add
some learners that are very
introspective and like to think things
through themselves and so just providing
that pause time for them to be able to
do that and so in an online environment
it might be through some sort of a
discussion board where you know maybe
you're not forcing them to respond to
anybody else's thoughts you're just
giving them an opportunity to put their
own thoughts down or maybe it's a guided
reflection reflective journal where over
the course of the class they've got to
do an entry once a day once a week once
a however that is structured and so it's
it's you know there's as I said earlier
there's not a magic bullet that is gonna
fit everybody which is is challenging
but it also can be can be fun because it
gives us as the educators the
opportunity to try out some different
things and to experiment a little bit
and one of the things that and I try to
model this in in my own professional
life too it's it's about not being
satisfied with the status quo and it's
about trying out new things I mentioned
earlier I'm trying out the flipped
classroom and this is the second
semester now I've done that and I'll I
went through the learning cycle myself
the first semester and figured out some
things that worked and some things that
didn't work and so now I'll do that but
you know I'm I'm tenured so it's little
bit easier for me to be a little bit
more flexible and spontaneous the
untenured faculty probably have to be a
little bit more focused and a little bit
more norm reference yeah
lady flit what does it mean well has
been that the face-to-face time is the
the instructor lecturing and giving
information and then the students then
outside a class time
take that information and apply it
through some sort of a problem set
homework project etc the flipped
classroom does that 180 and so you
create a way to deliver the lecture part
outside a classroom perhaps through some
online recorded lectures readings those
sorts of things then you use the class
time that face-to-face time for problem
activities inquiry activities those
sorts of things to where if we think
about are you guys familiar with Bloom's
taxonomy and the levels of cognition so
delivering the lecture part that's
oftentimes at lower levels of Bloom's
taxonomy the problem sets are at the
upper levels of Bloom's taxonomy so we
when they're with us under expert
supervision we're doing the low level
stuff we send them home by themselves to
work on the upper level stuff they've
reached a problem where they're
struggling and they're stuck and so the
flipped classroom you do that just 180
to where they're doing the higher level
stuff with you to where you're helping
them work through issues and challenges
and things and so it's again it it it
has not been a perfect switch for me I'm
knocking on wood that the second
iteration will go a little bit smoother
than the first iteration but it's and
it's a different model for the students
because the students aren't used to that
and so it takes a little bit of training
on their part to get them prepared for
that
yeah yeah you have to get them focused
on actual learning as opposed to just
getting the grade which that can be
challenging on some of these students so
are we how we doing thank you thank you
Geneva
this has been a production of Cornell
University on the web at Cornell edu